in entrepreneurship in silicon valley
there's this mentality and we had this
on the early days of the campaign
for andrews like move fast and break
things right don't ask for permission
ask for forgiveness right just go go go
and that works in a lot of ways and for
a society you're almost forgiving of
that right like
if you look at facebook or google where
they were like darlings in the beginning
and now they're kind of villains because
we gave them a little runway and they
say what you will um but in healthcare
moving fast and breaking things means
moving fast and probably killing people
right or really really seriously hurting
people's health like you can't be that
cavalier
in healthcare like how how did that
mentality
kind of bake into to where you um
frankly ended up starting your own thing
you're right and i think i mean for
silicon valley i think there are some
learnings there
because it's tough to move fast and
break things but then actually
if we look back in the history of
healthcare we do see some of the answers
so we look at how
new medical devices or surgical
techniques have been rolled out
from x-rays to mri machines if we look
at
how new drugs and medications have been
rolled out as well we have a lot of
innovation in health care
um that has bubbled up across different
countries
and different parts of healthcare and
once we
evaluate and show that it's relatively
safe it's about having a clear mechanism
for rolling that out at scale
because i think many systems are great
at having if they've got a new
blockbuster drug to tackle lung cancer
making that available nationwide but if
we have
a revolutionary technology or
a digital platform that allows people to
receive mental health treatment
um on their smartphone and it does it's
been shown to improve outcomes
actually rolling that out is pretty
difficult
and we haven't created the networks and
the pathways
to make that happen fast and i think
that's
that's the balance we need to be able to
evaluate
and safely develop new innovations and
solutions
but once we've demonstrated they're safe
we want to be able to roll it out super
fast
so that everyone who can benefit from
them
does benefit from them so
is that a policy issue is that a
business issue
is that a bureaucracy issue what what
solves that
all of the above great so i i
it's it's not i mean it's not
straightforward i think if we look at
healthcare
it's it's complex it involves a lot of
stakeholders
it's regulated and all of that tends to
slow a lot of innovation down and even
i mean if you take how let's say apple
innovates the iphone
um the people who are using the iphone
and the people who are building it and
the people who are trying to think of
new ways to
optimize different features are all the
same people very frequently
and they'll all be people who are buying
their own um smartphones
and then they're going home in the
evening and maybe they're kind of trying
out a new app
and that tight alignment between those
stakeholders makes it really easy
to innovate to improve to adopt i think
in healthcare it's very different
the people who are paying for healthcare
are sometimes different from the people
who need healthcare
who are different from the people who
are administering or prescribing it who
are in turn different from the people
coming up with new solutions
right you've got patients you've got
professionals and physicians
you've got health insurance companies
hospitals
and then you've got people who are
focusing on different forms of r d be it
research scientists to data scientists
to developers
to people building startups and so
creating that alignment
and the challenges with it i think are
some of the reasons why healthcare
hasn't been able to transform
and embrace technology in the way that
many many other sectors already have
and it's been a bit left behind the
challenge that
creates is how we also build businesses
that align with government policies
because again
if healthcare is more complex it takes
more time to build successful businesses
that are sustainable and that has an
impact on business models it has an
impact on how they're funded on venture
capital
um and you one requires or needs to be
more patient
it's very difficult to see the growth
that we've seen with ride sharing
also occur with healthcare services or
digital first healthcare services and
that's why
i mean we need a combination of
governments and policymakers working
with
entrepreneurs so that we can create
long-term sustainable
solutions in healthcare um otherwise
frankly
entrepreneurs and high quality
entrepreneurs can be turned off
building solutions in health you just
hit something really really key i never
thought of before
and i imagine most people think about it
where almost every other business
the people creating it are a form of a
customer
or usually the customer you know if
you're creating an app you're creating
something that you would want to use
right you're solving a problem in your
life if you're a chef and you're going
to cook something great
it's probably because you love food
right and so there's a certain
connectivity between the creation
the process of creating it the delivery
of the creation and then the actual end
product
but if you're trying to
let's say cure cancer let's say and
alzheimer's or als or what go down the
list right
you by definition don't have that
disease you don't have that
problem realistically because if you're
sick you actually can't most likely
create that so the
there's a disconnect i imagine between
the creator and the end user that's so
void right you imagining this army of
young people
who understand new technologies helping
80 to 90 year old
americans who grew up in a generation
that that didn't have that am i
am i hitting that right that's what
that's i think you're saying you're
exactly right
exactly and that's kind of one big
challenge in healthcare i think another
one
is that unfortunately the people who
need healthcare the most
are usually the ones who are least
likely to use technology
right to your point someone who's got
severe dementia
they're in their late 80s they've had a
hip replacement
it's unlikely they're going to just pop
on a fitbit and start monitoring their
health
right and and that presents an
additional entrepreneurial challenge but
it also means that
if we're not careful healthcare can
actually widen inequalities
because it's the healthiest people who
are going to use the latest technology
um rather than addressing those
inequalities talk to me about
your company sarah because what i love
about your company is you tie it to the
human side
because you're doing a lot of at-home
healthcare work which is some of the
most important
and less almost like least talked about
form of work
a lot of people think we can have an
army of home health care workers
um when it's a really really hard job um
it's physically taxing it's
demanding it's uh sometimes infuriating
um
tell us about what you've done and like
how you've looked at that that lens
we're just talking about where like the
disconnect in healthcare products and
healthcare
innovation creation if you will yeah so
i had the entrepreneurial bug
and i think after my spend spending my
time in the nhs i realized
there was this disconnect between the
people who were receiving
health technologies and the benefits
from them versus people who really
needed it
and i think it hit home the hardest when
my mother actually fractured her back
and she needed
care and support at home and we as a
family we tried to organize it
and it was really difficult um because
we tried calling different home care
companies and i did and
most of them were just too overwhelmed
and too busy they had
people they were already looking after
they didn't have carers available
um and even when i called them and i
said hey you're busy but do you mind
dropping me a line back
sometimes it'd be days before they
called me back and that was a real shame
because and a challenge because at a
point of crisis
you would go to a care company for peace
of mind but actually
they were making the journey more
difficult and it's not because they're
not motivated i think there are a lot of
very motivated very resilient very
good-hearted people in the care sector
it's just that they don't have the tools
and if you walk into a typical home care
agency
they're literally using a whiteboard pen
and paper
to manage their day-to-day operations i
mean i've been in home care agencies
where they don't they're not even using
the internet um and
so with those tools or lack of it
becomes really difficult
to manage your day-to-day and to
organize for caregivers
to visit people in their homes look
after them and then go to other visits
it's like lyft trying to coordinate its
operations
without using any form of technology no
one has smartphones yeah
it's like you're yeah it's i mean it's
almost impossible right and
so that was i mean that really hit home
and that kind of for me was an
inspiration for trying to build
a digital first home care company um
that really was able to push the
boundaries on
empowering older people to live better
lives in their own homes
rather than going to care homes or or
hospitals or elsewhere
and to use technology to give people the
tools they need
so that they can provide great care
rather than them being continuously
overwhelmed
and caught up with administrative work a
bit like when i was a junior doctor
and i spent most of my day um doing
admin and paperwork
rather than actually focusing on patient
care so when you in your model
you can find but i'm assuming your
mother could sign herself up but you
could probably do it for her as well
like
that time of bridging the gap exactly so
we digitize
the whole care process from how
someone's on board
to how carers are recruited to the
matching of carers and users based on
different characteristics such as time
location the skills of the care of the
needs of the individual
automating a lot of the back office
which takes the headache out
and also digitalizing the user
experience for everyone involved
the carer the person receiving care
the family member all of them have an
app that they can use to monitor manage
the
the service and it also from a
headquarters an
operations point of view it gives us
real-time insight into the care that's
being provided in someone's home
and that's really important because in a
typical home care company a carer will
visit someone in the home
and they will write up using pen and
paper notes
everything that happened in the visit
because they're required to by the
regulator and then go to the next one
but if something's gone wrong or the
carer doesn't know what to do
apart from calling up the agency which
many of the times
they're too busy speaking to other
carers or trying to sort out sort out
another issue that's cropped up apart
from calling them they have no way of
contacting anyone and getting support
and that's an incredibly disempowering
experience if you're a carer
to go and visit someone let's say
they're more drowsy than usual they
haven't been taking their medications
you don't know what to do
and then you've got to go to your next
visit that is a really i mean it's a
very concerning it's quite a scary
position to be in
but by simply using our app our carers
can communicate with other carers they
can communicate with our team
and the family and all happens in real
time so what is
normally a disempowering experience
becomes one where they feel comfortable
they feel safe they feel supported in
delivering a great care
and that's how we've used digital and
we've seen loads of metrics improve as a
result
from the quality of the care to the
staff experience to the way we're
retaining staff so that
doubles actually after we've rolled our
app and given people it
to our ability to identify health issues
in the people we're looking after much
much earlier on because everything's
digital everything's real time
it's all connected as opposed to using a
very traditional system
which sometimes takes weeks to pick up
an issue
and it fundamentally allows us to
provide a safer
higher quality and more peace of mind
service
um that also is financially more
sustainable
uh for the sector as well we're able to
pay caregivers better
we're able to charge less for care it's
a system that hopefully works in the
best interest of everyone
because we've been able to use
[Music]
technology
[Music]
you